are you born again that's the critical
question have you been born again yeah
yeah well I'm I'm a Catholic you know
what I mean I'm a little different but
so you died tonight would you go to
heaven I like to think so oh so then
you're night born again well well I'm a
Catholic because you're only thinking
let me ask you this did Jesus die for
your sins yeah he did okay he did all
right he died for your sins did he take
them away did he take away your sins yes
okay so if you were to died tonight
would you go to
heaven well you just told me he took
away your sins see see I'm a I'm a
Catholic so we got a little different
but we got a little different different
beliefs we don't we don't think you can
just get baptized and go to heaven